let's see how good my memory is okay i'm
going to draw for you at least i'm going
to try
a parallel line through that point there
maybe i should give it a name
let's call it point p okay it goes
through p
but it's
parallel to av okay
so here's the way i'm gonna do it see if
it works out and um
then we'll do it step by step and you
can copy me okay
so here's the first thing i'm going to
do
okay i'm going to stick the point of my
compass
on to p which is going to be um
difficult i don't know if it's going to
rub it out but
we'll find out in a second so here we go
i'm on
there okay it's meant to be but it's
kind of um
yeah it's kind of hold on there you go
right so i'm going to draw a point
there i'm going to bend around
be careful because it's actually sliding
so hopefully your points
will actually stick into your page a
little bit okay
okay all right now next thing i'm going
to do
is i'm going to put the point of the
compass
on wherever i intersected with a b okay
so that's going to be over here now that
length should still be the same i
haven't changed the length of the
compass
now i'm going to come around to wow
okay last one last one
i'm still waiting
okay see that mark i just made down here
right the second one on a b
i'm going to put my point there like so
and now i'm going to i moved i think oh
no it should be right well let's see if
it works out
i'm going to draw one more arc that
intersects with oh look i'm rubbing it
out
that intersects with my first arc over
here okay like so
now unfortunately like i said you know
when i put this on even though it sucks
it moves so yours will be better than
mine because
when the uh when you put your cup's
point in unless you rip your book it's
not going to go anywhere
now this is now where i'm going to draw
my um parallel line
oh fingerprints
i'm still waiting for everyone to have
nothing in their hands
excellent take my original point and
where these two lines is now do you
remember by the way when we started
talking about angles
these two lines which are actually part
of a very small part of circle we gave
them a name starting with a does anyone
remember
they're little arcs aren't they right oh
they are adjacent but anyway
so where those arcs intersect
okay what do you think content does it
look pretty parallel
now i think yours should look even more
parallel than mine because like i said
my my compass is waving around a little
bit
so let's give it a go shall we oh one
more thing one more thing
i know a question
not at the end
i've just put these arrows on lines not
at the ends of the lines
to indicate that they go in the same
direction no is mentioning
they should in theory if they kept going
forever never touch
they go forever and ever and they'll
never get closer to each other
okay